when it comes to the blockbuster success
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe there's
a ton of factors that have built the
franchise into what it is today but it
was the 1998 release of blade a gory
action movie packed with leather coats
and thrilling set pieces that first
broke the comic movie mold in the 90s
and showed longtime readers and
mainstream audiences alike that Marvel
comics could be cool but the 1998
release a blade isn't the whole story in
fact there's a lot you might not know
about your favorite bloodsucker busting
hero here's the untold truth of blade
tomb of Dracula blade was created by
Gene Colan and Marv Wolfman in 1973
during the run on the tomb of Dracula
series which followed a group of
characters tasked with killing the Lord
of vampires it wasn't just a horror
comic however the series brought Dracula
directly into the Marvel Universe with
crossovers and super-powered guest stars
readers eventually learned that blades
real name was Eric Brooks and that he
had received both his strength and his
hatred for vampires from his mother who
was bitten by a vampire while she was
giving birth to him the event gave him
immunity to vampirism as well as a
prolonged lifespan and fangs after tomb
of Dracula's final issue blade popped up
now and again in the Marvel Universe
whenever a title needed a dose of horror
blade the movie it was the release of
blade in 1998 they've catapulted the
character to new creative heights the
movie reinvigorated the concept of a
vampire like vampire hunter showcasing a
character that lived in the shadows
killing sleazy vampires and outlandish
action sequences although the movie was
directed by Steve Norrington producer
and star Wesley Snipes deserves a
massive amount of credit for the
character stature in pop culture history
Snipes would constantly adjust shots and
ad-lib certain lines dialogue or scenes
that while costly were always beneficial
to the final cut Snipes even ad-libbed
one of the most famous lines of the
movie someone's always trying to educate
oval blade to blade was a smash success
with an incredible idea for a planned
sequel at the end of the film blade and
Caron picked themselves up and there are
hundreds and hundreds of vampires out on
the streets and it's become
the vampires Norrington turned down the
opportunity to direct the sequel leaving
the chair open for guillermo del toro to
step in for Blade 2 in 2002 the film
followed blade as he was forced to team
up with a group of specially trained
vampires to hunt a powerful mutant
aberration of vampires called Reapers
the film turned out to be a success but
it's arguably most notable for featuring
a murderer's row of character actors who
would go on to major acclaim including
Norman Reedus Donnie Yen and Ron Perlman
critics were lukewarm but fans turned
out in force turning blade from a
one-off hit into a genuine franchise
blade Trinity Blade 2 had moved the
franchise forward but blade Trinity went
off the rails directed by series writer
David Goyer it intended to bring in more
of the classic elements from the comics
like vampire detective Hannibal King and
Dracula unfortunately by all accounts it
was a disaster for everyone involved
Patton Oswalt recalled his time on the
set with a series of stranger than
fiction anecdotes about wesley snipes he
would communicate with with post-its
that he would give to the director and
each one he would sign blade for his
part
Snipes found the situation so unpleasant
that he filed a lawsuit against Goyer
the producers and New Line Cinema citing
among other things the juvenile level of
humor in the screenplay as well as the
increased focus on blade sidekicks blade
Trinity ended up being the worst
reviewed movie of the trilogy and put a
stake through the heart of the franchise
but as with any good vampire blade
wouldn't stay dead for long Blade TV in
2006 blade would return on the small
screen and Spike TV's blade the series
Snipes was replaced by rapper Kirk
sticky Fingaz Jones for the show which
continued the events of the movies while
the show is expanding mythology seemed
intriguing to series slowly hemorrhage
viewers until the season finale a slow
bleed that seemed oddly fitting for the
vampire show blade in the Marvel
Universe while the blade television show
spelled the end of the characters
live-action adaptations a new comic book
was released less than a week after the
show's final episode air the series
combined blades original comic book
origin with his
more popular movie personality this new
version of blade kneecapped spider-man
ode Wolverine a blood debt for saving
his life from a vampire years ago and
occasionally did odd jobs for shield
while the comic only lasted 12 issues it
did have one of the oddest team ups in
Marvel history Doctor Doom kidnapped
blade to assist him in saving an
innocent life from vampires the catch
the victim was dr. Doom's mother a
Romani sorceress who was attacked by
vampires decades ago but was saved by
blade going back in time to save her
most importantly the reasons doom knew
it was specifically blade who saved his
mother was that he had perfect recall
even as a fetus burrows blade in Britain
Wesley Snipes portrayal was so
successful that it's easy to forget that
blade was born and raised in London in
the original comics after the
cancellation of the rebooted Blade comic
he appeared in the ensemble cast of
Captain Britain and mi 13 which followed
a group of British superhero is battling
magical threats while on the team blades
started a romantic relationship with
fellow team member spitfyre a vampire
with superhuman speed who'd been
fighting her bloodlust since World War
two having two vampires on the team
turned out to be a problem though when
Dracula launched an attack on Britain
from his secret castle on the moon blade
and the rest of my 13 were able to repel
Dracula's attack thanks to a captured
Duke of Hell a mystical skull that kept
vampires from invading Great Britain and
the mystical sword of Excalibur no one
ever said this stuff was easy blade the
Avenger while blade is most well known
for fighting vampires he's often found
himself at odds with a wide variety of
immortal beasts and demons in the Mighty
Avengers this involves secretly rallying
a team of heroes to fight the death
walkers for immortal rulers who each had
dominion over one of the elements
intriguingly this required blade to
adopt disguises so as not to alert the
death walkers first as Spider hero the
non-copyright-infringing Spider themed
hero of New York and then as Ronan a
catch-all ninja costume for superheroes
who need to go incognito don't worry he
eventually went back to his trademark
outfit
return to television while blade might
not currently have a comic series that
doesn't mean Marvel's forgotten about
him in fact there's a chance he might
return sooner than later specifically in
an upcoming season of the ABC series
Marvel's agents of shield a spokesperson
for Marvel tweeted out about the 2018
season with a hashtag blade leaving fans
to speculate that the show would
incorporate everyone's favorite vampire
hunter Snipes even responded to tweets
asking whether he would be willing to
reprise his role for Marvel saying when
anyone asks who could be the next blade
you already know there's only one blade
BAM balls in Marvel's court thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]